hello and hey guys I'm a beach art
welcome to Abby's kitchen now if you
guys caught my other pedo diet video my
girl Abbie Langer and I found this
really strange reddit thread where
people who were on keto diet reported
their favorite strange but delicious
pedo friendly okay Mac let's just say it
was a little extreme
now I was by no means of suggesting that
everybody on the keto diet or even a
large proportion of people on the Camino
diet actually ate that OH
however I get why so my viewers were a
little bit upset about it and saw that
and they were kind of sick okay so they
were like viciously pissed so jokes
aside in this video I actually plan to
break down the keto diet and give you a
comprehensive with you about what it
actually means and also what I think
about it so first of all what is the
keto diet well it's basically a diet
that consists of extremely high amounts
of fat it's only low amount of
carbohydrates and moderate amounts of
protein it's pretty restrictive they
consist of a lot of things like meat
cheese oils butters green and cut though
any kind of carbohydrates a foods like
potatoes right pasta bread Brut any kind
of starchy vegetable so in other words
it completely removed at least one
soldier the idea behind the keto diet is
he sent up for lime on glucose to fill
your body
the grapes down fast into plank called
ketone bodies and uses that as energy
instead so what are the benefits well
the guy was originally used to treat
athletic seizures in children and the
research in this area is super promising
and it's also being shown to help
potentially excrete other kind of
neurological diseases like Parkinson's
MS and Alzheimer's disease
there are also some studies that show
that may help
purse electrical levels into the list IQ
diabetes as well as potentially interest
cholesterol levels as well so I'm
definitely excited about these
therapeutic benefits in clinical
settings however the recent fascination
of using the keto diet and rapid weight
loss is where I get concerned
I mean sure you're probably going to
lose weight any time you cut out one or
more major sinkers you've got fewer food
choices and you eat less and there's
also a lot of research comparing low
carb diets like the keto diet to low fat
diet and while low carbs tend to lose
weight faster by about the one-year mark
that weight lost levels out and there
really isn't any difference between the
low carbs and the low fat diet the
reason why you may lose weight really
quickly on the keto diet is because
glycogen which is our carbohydrate store
in our body is bound up with water so
when you lose your glycogen stores
because you're not eating any carbs you
tend to just drop a lot of water weight
so in other words that rapid weight loss
is not so much fat as it is just a lot
of water having said that one of the
nice things about the keto diet is that
it tends to reduce our hunger hormone
Raylan
so a lot people in the Kyodai report
being less hungry on that diet and they
would being on another kind of
restrictive diet but as with any
restrictive diet I still have some major
concerns my first concern is that it's a
really hard diet to stick to I mean the
keto diet has surprisingly high dropout
rate because people just find it so
painfully restrictive and hard to stick
to and we also often report feeling
cranky and fatigued when they cut out
carbs especially at the beginning
they're when your body is just not
accustomed to using ketone bodies as
energy another potential impact is a
loss of muscle mass which we know it's
so important to boosting our metabolism
in the long run a lot of people think
that big muscles of a responsibility of
protein
and floating alone but that is just not
true when you eat carbs can get an
insulin response and insulin is kind of
like the key to helping that protein and
get into the muscles help our muscles
grow no carbohydrate no insulin response
and no muscle growth also cards give you
that quick little bout of energy so you
can push it in the gym so you might
benefit harder to work out when you're
on the keto diet another uncomfortable
side effect that I hear from a lot of
people is constipation when you're
coming out a lot of those really fiber
rich green fruits and starchy vegetables
you may find yourself getting a little
backed up and that is never fun a huge
concern about cutting out any kind of
food group is that you may be missing
out on really vital nutrients and
minerals so indicate sukhino diet that's
usually things like sodium chloride
potassium vitamin D and calcium these
are so important you definitely want to
be making sure to supplement if you're
going to eat oh you'll also want to keep
an eye on your blood works because
eschewed max a nutrient distribution of
this diet Risa suggests the potato diet
may increase the risk of high
cholesterol so if you've got a
pre-existing heart condition this may
not be the guy for you so as always be
sure to speak to your doctor before
starting any kind of diet but especially
an extreme one like them finally my
biggest beef with any kind of
restrictive eating pattern but
especially something as Extreme as the
keto diet is that it may encourage
disordered eating behaviors restricting
counting and obsessing over food is
definitely not healthy and it can make
social situations around food super very
anxiety promoting activities I am a big
believer that everything especially
carbs can be enjoyed in moderation and
that the best diet for you is the diet
that you find most legible that also
meets your body's uniqueness so guys I
hope this gave you a well-rounded
overview as
you diet and what I really want you to
remember is that above all food it
should be pleasurable it should not be a
big for and if you are going on a diet
like the keto diet or really any other
diet and take that away from you it's
definitely not a good place to be so
guys I hope you loved this video if you
did be sure to give it a thumbs up leave
your comments below with your thoughts
on the keto diet subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen by
[Music]